Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your
host Paul aka Ryan Seacrest Invasion and this
video we're talking about what's going on
with Everett Ross.
Heavy Spoilers ahead for Secret Invasion so
if you haven't checked out Episode 1 then
check out now.
Everything from this point onwards is going
ruin the episode and staying past this point
would be a weird Hill to die on.
Ooop spoiling it with the puns already but
yeah we have a lot to talk about.
Now the episode opens with Everett Ross meeting
a crazy conspiracy theorist named Agent Prescod.
Finding out that he has damning evidence of
the Skrulls plans Prescod lashes out at him
which is when he's killed by the character.
Ross runs off into the night pursued by a
shadowy figure and it's from this point that
it all hits the fans.
Falling to his death it's revealed that he's
a skrull and chances are that this completely
blew your mind.
-
Now I used to be like you.
Not a chump but still someone who didn't know
what was going on but the more Ive thought
about it the more it's became clear.
Everyone is asking if he's been a skrull the
whole time but there's actually a lot of clues
that that isn't the case.
Now in order to talk about this I have to
go into the Skrull immitation ritual that
we see being carried at during the first episode.
This happens in the restricted area of the
power plant in which we see a warrior copying
one of the anti-Russian Americans.
Now in order to immitate someone a skrull
has to at first see them and this then allows
them duplicate their look.
This was first shown in Captain Marvel when
Talos and his forces showed up on the beach.
Two of them looked over and then mimicked
a surfer and they had to see her in order
to do this.
It's the same with the soldier here and thus
Skrulls have to see someone so that they can
become a copy.
This just gives them a frame of reference
and it's like when you're an artist and you
use something to base your own work off.
So Ross at some point would've had to have
been a real person so that the Skrull could
copy them in the first place.
Sure they could've grown up as him but at
some point they'd have to work their way through
the security sector in order to get to the
top.
It's far easier to copy someone whos already
in that position instead of playing that person
since birth so you can then get into it.
Now Ross would be the perfect target for a
Skrull to immitate as well and it means that
they could just take a short cut when they
were copying his look.
Firstly he was high up in American security
and also married to Val who herself's a big
name too.
Add to this the fact that he also had an in
with Wakanda and this would make him an extremely
valuable target.
This is a guy who has his hand in two of the
most powerful countries on earth and thus
I think they sought him out rather than a
skrull always being him.
Now Ross has also done something recently
that makes him a very valuable asset.
Caught giving secrets to Wakanda he was arrested
by Val and carted off to prison.
At this point he was then freed by Okoye and
it's from here that he likely had to lie low.
Now this would provide the skrulls with the
perfect opportunity to grab him as he's in
a very vunerable position and left out there
on his own.
He can't turn to the CIA because they're after
him now and thus he couldn't go to them for
help if he found out he'd been copied.
He can however turn to shield but its unlikely
that he would because like I said he's just
been sprung from jail.
However a Skrull wouldnt have any qualms about
this and they may have captured him and then
took him into the plant.
Copying him from this point is the perfect
point to take over and this is something that
we've seen happen in the comics.
The Skrulls tended to mimic someone when they
were completely on their own at a point where
they could be swapped out without anyone noticing.
They couldve seen that Ross was struggling
on his own and theres plenty of opportunity
with where we last left him.
No one of the big weaknesses of the skrulls
is that theyre not perfect copies and they
often get sniffed out because of their poor
personalities.
Not slagging you guys off yeah...I'm sure...I'm
sure youre really nice but it's something
that's happened to them throughout the comics
and movies.
Skrulls had difficulty copying mannerisms
and under interrogation they didn't hold up.
For example we see in Captain Marvel how Talos
uses the wrong name with Nick and also tries
to bluff his way through conversations about
their shared history.
This is something that often alerted the heroes
in the comics as Skrulls couldnt really copy
someone down to that level.
Now I will talk about the machine they have
in the show but I doubt that a Skrull wouldve
copied Ross back when he was giving Val his
own invasion in secret.
What?
Now Val like Fury is someone who has very
few friends and she's immediately suspicious
of everyone she meets.
In the comics a Skrull actually took on the
form of Val and she and Fury ended up spending
a romantic night together.
The next day Fury was incredibly suspicious
and he followed her out when she said she
was getting breakfast.
This took him to an alleyway where she saw
her meeting a contact and he instantly realised
that something was off.
Back at their room he then shot and killed
her which is when it was revealed that she
was a Skrull.
Now Val is exactly the same as Fury in that
she doesnt trust anyone.
Thus i think becoming Ross would be the wrong
thing to do if they were in a relationship.
She'd probably sniff him out and realise that
something was off and would likely be aware
of Skrulls anyway because of her security
clearance.
So I cant see a Skrull immitating him then
and I think at the very least they'd wait
until the pair divorced.
We also don't know what kinds of mutants there
are knocking about in the MCU and in the comics
these could easily catch Skrulls out as well.
Wolverine has a heightened sense of smell
so he could tell if someone was faking it
and Professor X could read minds and deduce
it from that as well.
Now again Wakanda is a highly advanced civilsation
too and they probably have the tech to sniff
out foreign entities.
Shuri of course operated on Ross after he
got shot and it's likely she'd discover he
was a skrull during this time.
So it has to have happened after that in order
for things to work and thus Ross couldn't
have been one as recently as that.
Now I personally think that he was likely
grabbed after escaping the van as he probably
tried to make his way out of the US.
Wanted in the country he may have done an
Edward Snowden which wouldve probbaly taken
him all the way to Russia.
This would allow the Skrulls the perfect chance
to grab him and they could then take over
as him and go and work with Shield.
Now the memory machines have also had some
upgrades too and we see them possessing far
more power than what they've had before.
They can now hold someone in place and the
Skrulls can pull all of their memories out
which will help them fake people better when
it comes to these kinds of Agents.
I doubt Hill wouldve just let him in the organisation
and he probably had to pass some tests to
at least prove that it was him.
Having these memories though allowed for him
to work his way in and this is why she seems
so shocked when she sees him on the ground.
She genuinely believed that this was actually
Everett Ross and I was surprised that her
and Fury didnt talk about it at some point.
Potentially theyre all just as confused as
we are but it was a weird omission to not
have it brought up.
Now the reason I think it wasn't is because
theyre not that alarmed because they dont
think that he's been a skrull this entire
time.
Talos probably filled them in and it means
that Ross is out there and likely still under
the capture of the Skrulls.
Now I do think that at some point we will
see him come back and he's probably someone
they'll rescure later on in the show.
Makes sense to have some characters we care
about being held captive by the skrulls as
itll add more emotion to the rescue scene
when they finally free them all.
So in the end I think that the Skrulls became
aware of Agent Prescod and thus they sent
someone in who could find out what was going
on.
Ross seemed like the best fit and thus he
was then chosen and this is when Talos got
wise to their plan.
At least that's what I think when we talk
about this reveal.
Might be right might be wrong but I'd love
to hear your thoughts on it in the comments
below.
If you want to support the channel for as
little as 99 cents a month then please click
the join button below and as a thank you you'll
get early access to videos every week.
We also have our merch store over at shopzeroedition.com
which sells lots of nerdy inspired t-shirts
hats and more.
We've just launched a secret invasion slash
pulp fiction inspired t-shirt so if you wanna
head over there and help us out then the links
in the description.
Now if you want something else to watch we
have a video on screen right now _____________________
With that out the way, huge thank you for
sitting through the video, I've been your
host and I'll see you next time.
Take care, Peace.